[Music]
we talk a lot about networks
most people don't have any idea how big
their networks in fact really are your
networks are enormous
i mean you start with the people in the
room
you start with everybody they know
you start with people that they know
you you look at graduates of stanford
you know people that they know the
places that they've worked before you
know it you can define your network
literally as being hundreds of thousands
of people
because any any anybody who can make a
connection to somebody that might be
willing to help you is in fact part of
your network and you may not even know
who they are
but they're part of your network and you
can make that work for you
if you want to meet somebody
somebody usually somebody in the
stanford business school alumni
community will make that introduction
for you if you can figure out the right
way to get to them and the right way to
ask that question
gsb alums will usually help
i'll make this point because i i always
make it
and that is
almost anybody is going to be willing to
help you
i'd be willing to help you your
classmates will be willing to help you
your professors and alumni will be
willing to help you but very few of them
are going to be willing to do your
homework for you
and so
an example
if you call me and say
tom i want to get into
you know
i don't know
venture capital
would you introduce me to some venture
capitalists
what
that's a lazy question
okay
but if you said i've got two years in
the venture capital industry
and
i
worked on a project
that
you know
you know
josh green at more davidow is a board
member of i know you know josh because i
know you work with him on a board
would you be willing to introduce me to
josh uh josh green so that i could have
a conversation about this project that i
know he's interested in okay that now
the night and day those two questions
the first one general requires work on
my part
and i'm not going to go do a lot of work
to try to figure out what you could have
figured out and didn't
but the second one
if if i believe that that's a very
credible question it takes me about 30
seconds to pop off an email to josh and
say look this is somebody i think i
think you ought to meet
and they've they've specifically picked
you out of the hundreds or thousands of
venture capital people because of your
experience in this company and they're
interested in that and they think they
have something to add would you meet
with them for you know 15 20 minutes
specific on the one hand general on the
other hand
as i said pick specific targets make
specific requests and if somebody does
you a favor particularly somebody who
didn't have any reason to do it other
than they were just trying to help you
after the thing is done you met with
joshua water go back send them an email
and tell them what happened
hey i met with josh thanks for setting
that up i'm not sure what's going to
come out of it but i really appreciate
it we're going to stay in touch thank
you believe me that will pay dividends
later first of all it's just good common
courtesy if somebody did something for
you that they didn't have to do to call
them up and thank them and tell them
what happened because they're probably
curious
it also leaves that door open to go back
to him again in the future because
they've got a good good feeling about
you this is somebody that handled that
right and they'd be willing to go do
another favor for you down the road
whereas
you know i've got a lot of people i i
won't name them maybe i will later if
you but
who seems like every couple of years
would call me up and say tom
it's been so long since we've talked i
would want i really wanted to get back
to you and see how you were doing
well i'm doing fine
how are you doing well i you know i
didn't work out i was looking for a job
well what happened with the last thing
that you called me about two years ago
that you never came back and told me
what happened about that and
you know
maybe i'll be polite to them maybe i
won't more likely they don't somehow i'm
out of town or something when that call
comes in and
and my ea just handles it and it never
sees the light of day
stay connected to the people who've
helped you
[Music]